[Música]
instalada en un país es donde la
opacidad bancaria está a la orden del
día una sociedad offshore tiene un
objetivo principal lograr ganar dinero
esas firmas abren una empresa fantasma
en un paraíso fiscal la mayoría de las
veces basta con un simple buzón de
correo gracias a un sistema de
testaferros en la identidad del
individuo o de la empresa no aparece en
ningún lado se crea una nueva cuenta
bancaria y a continuación se pueden
adquirir productos de todo tipo con
total discreción como inmuebles aviones
privados o yates otros beneficios para
los clientes menores costos de gestión y
más flexibilidad en las condiciones de
ingresos estos paraísos fiscales existen
en todo el mundo los más conocidos
panamá y las vírgenes británicas obedece
también hay estados territorios como
hong kong y singapur y países europeos
con suiza y chipre a la cabeza otros más
sorprendentes los estados de nevada
dakota del sur y delaware en eeuu pero
todo esto es ilegal no necesariamente de
hecho la sutileza de estos montajes
coquetea permanentemente con la
legalidad a esto se le llama
optimización fiscal no es objetable a
diferencia del blanqueo de capitales y
la evasión fiscal
según los cálculos del economista
gabriel suwwan en 2017 los paraísos
fiscales contenían cerca de 8 billones
de euros esto es 3 veces el producto
interno bruto de francia